joey van Kampen all a gather
strawberries in the last remaining days
of this year season bulging with juice
flavor and sweetness there a reminder
perhaps of a forgotten era but unless
you travel to his farm near nivelle in
Belgium you're unlikely to share the
experience they're destined for his farm
shop not the supermarket's the reason
unfair trading practices which in the
absence of effective EU legislation
parliament has become trying to improve
in gaad's office hacer por todo amarjeet
m'avais como day in Tahiti yeah paces yo
foo DMV Okinawa said Allah says oh pisco
parmo yvonne de moi ave passavant in
mopey de moi someone the the quantity is
on dick like a Latina detective on a
locker like a little Buffett oh did mr.
van Campen all I learned from the
experience like on sofas poovar devote
oporto a improve our depression sueli
predictor says SEO OS margin super
depend on queda cerca nola the vote is
apology for lagoon he farms around 36
Hector's and now sells principally
wholesale and at the shop a resolution
passed in parliament for measures to
improve the food supply chain may
encourage him there's a lot to be fixed
says the polish mep leading the dr
edward chessick tony termina vez de
Poitiers a destruction product a
Venusian ian are the stars are cosmic
upward who cover it she promised a knee
yay groovy Shanna Shanna cost of cheetah
transport oh she magazine lavanya exotic
oof mep is highlight a situation where
suppliers are forced to sell it below
production costs or bear the cost of
supermarket offers consumers are in turn
hit they say by pure choice so too is
innovation do zhe my own resonant
instead of data leach Nam Asians custom
as a possible Vanya not
productiveness Java of those starts
we've got the scent of some to the
easiest question no nuclear 11-8
possesses like the initiative starts a
wagon Otto Victorian valium plz an
overwhelming majority of MEP is voted to
support mr. chessex report produced at
Parliament's own initiative and
therefore not binding on the Commission
post a Gooney Bird essential need savini
God near zara be as naughty product are
a Bonita eco-chic possible Vasudeva
Spanish 6 and Agnes costly for Sonya the
ball is now in the court of the European
Commission to answer these demands